[Applaudissements]
rappel d'isabelle morini-bosc parce que
vous ne la voyez plus est quand même en
train de se déguiser en autoroute et va
chanter halo halo l'ordinateur tout à
l'heure alors justement les tue l'amour
on s'est dit bon c'est vrai que là on
parle de passion de rose d'amour mais il
ya aussi ce qu'on appelle le tue l'amour
alors chacun a nous a donné son tue
l'amour vous nous donnerez qu'est ce qui
t'a qu'est-ce qui tue l'amour pour vous
qu'est ce que vous voulez pas avoir avec
une femme dans une relation ça vous met
sa caste ou ça casse tout haut niveau
caractériel c'est une jalousie extrême
casque oui mais mais mais mais au lit
par exemple qu'est-ce qui est ce qu est
ce que vous n'aimez pas chez une femme
belle semaine et du ketchup d'aller lit
par exemple avant l'arrivée rarement
quand même
françois viot vous alors vous vous
n'aimez pas les personnes qui parlent
pendant l'amour je vais faire marie
caroline si tu nous regardes ce soir je
peux te dire que je n'ai jamais supporté
que tu fasses la commentatrice hippiques
pendant qu'on faisait l'amour je sais je
attendez vous pressent qu'elle disait
que jacquot nantais voit la course en
tête à tête à trois temps quatre
longueurs de retard
est ce que le travail est de taille non
non non non quand même pas mais ça me
tuer mais tous mes effets ticket qui ne
supporte pas qu'on parle pendant l'amour